hello everyone my name is Kevin and if
you weren't hurt pronounce my last name
its Janowski it's if you looking for
ethnic origin its polish so there you go
and then a little bit more about me is
that damn tech enthusiast I'm originally
from Chicago go to town and I move up to
LA about three and a half years ago so
oh there's me and urban lights right
here and okay that's fine and then so
but anyway let get to the meat of the
topic why interactive maps so pretty
much what candy do well they can so
changes over time and they can toggle
through different variables and and
throw this talk I'll be talking about my
own personal experience with a you know
with or without my interactive map and
you can toggle through different
variables like different different
things you want to look through and and
they can also illuminate distinct
geographic boundaries like God through
like two different items you're looking
at so you can cup your map in different
areas when I recall them different types
of polygons and then you can kind of see
what things from over time and of course
you can see how a certain variable
changes over time per given area so
here's a cool example here I'm gonna
click this link really quickly I did not
make this I wish I could I wish I made
this okay here we go
so yes over here you can see here this
is like a chart of a king obesity rates
over time throughout the world this is a
gift so it maybe it's not totally an
interactive map but this is a kind of
idea we're looking for here we're
looking for changes over time for a
given area and of course with an
interactive map it'd be cool if some
cookies like say click here Canada or
the United States and see okay how is
how what's the obesity with exactly BC
rate for this country here for election
year 20 2006 so yes I got the link for a
metro calm calm it was awesome and just
so we know what you I'm comparing it to
I'm comparing this
interactive maps of static maps like
here's an example of a static map here
like this is a map showing God from
medium and showing like different like
the unemployment rate for different US
counties in 2016 and here's an
old-school Google Maps think Mountain
View when what happens there Mountain
View all right so drawbacks of
interactive maps so this is kind of like
the staying in general like why you
would not want to use an interactive map
so free much the reason why you not want
to use an interactive map is that you
can't lose control of the masses is it
in essence with without with an interact
with you know with an with a static map
you can deliver a precise concise
message with an interactive map you're
pretty much telling your users okay here
we go here's a data source here's a map
visualizing it here are some variables
you can you can switch around with it
what do you want it's kind of like it's
kind of you're telling your users you
make your own story so you kind of want
your users to at least have a good idea
of what the data means what and the way
it could be used for but before you make
it interactive map for but without
further ado we like to actually get to
more nitty-gritty stuff and just before
I you know I'm gonna talk about
interactive map I built a little bit so
pretty much the one I built for it was
for hack for a lay the organization and
it was a map with a explain call volumes
so the same way here know what's real
what true one is okay so just for
everyone here is not familiar 301 is
they call service you can call like it's
for non-emergency your students like if
someone like spray-painted your home or
so into a sofa on your front lawn or you
know stuff like that so you know you can
call 301 and they see you say valet
should send someone over take care of it
and you know keywords should and so you
know so pretty much I just looked at all
the trim on calls or are gonna request
matron one app from 2018-2019 and I kind
of show how its split by Neighborhood
Council within Los Angeles there 99
neighborhood councils make a prod and
they approximately like what will we
consider a neighborhood like it's a
Koreatown one there's a knuckle Park one
and so just give a quick preview here
quick rinse off while I build here so
this is Los Angeles proper I'll go over
here here's the the north near the
here's about the San Fernando Valley
over here here's the eastern eastern
side and you'll be down here it's around
you know they think think Long Beach
Redondo area around there and here's the
west side here so okay so can you all
see my hover point where I'll hover
hovering over right there okay so and
then just put a quick aside here la 32
neighborhood council that's where we're
at right now we're on the far eastern
part is the Cal State LA yeah this is
where we're at
la 32 NC and for the month of February
2019 there were approximately a little
less than 1400 requesting calls made
three one one so now I get to technical
stuff this means the code so but before
we can you know start making the map or
anything we gotta know the data so the
map is it's only as useful as data it's
displaying so you know so obviously we
have to go through data we have to make
sure there is you know there were
valleys for all the time periods you
were interested in so I had to kind of
go through data and kind of make sure
that there was you know like you know
there was a created date for every uh
well for mo for most values housing for
a - it was very large - it was like over
a million rows per year and he's growing
like 2018 it's bigger in 2017 and 2019
is bigger in 2018 we're not even doing
2019 yet so it's really one's getting a
popularity in LA and then of course
there should also be a change you know
there's to be a valley for every for
every boundary I'm interested in so in
my case like I want to make sure like
there's a valley for every neighbor
council here so every and so in
technical terms like everything here we
call the polygon since it has in your
regular shape so I wanna make sure I
really polygon here has a value and
from an interactive map here it is in
table form it's a panda's data frame and
really the table I was really really
interested in was to create a date
column here created a column there that
kind of just so is like if we wasn't
record like it shows like when request
was made and also shows the month it was
made in because I want to show how many
calls were made per month per year so
you know so if you go back here I kind
of had like requests like here from May
of twenty nineteen here here a
choropleth map of how it looks like of
the map straw LA and so reading the data
so pandas is the is it the facto choice
burying in data and for the most part
it's very effective it's simple straight
to the point you know you don't have to
be you have to be too sophisticated to
use it awesome and you know and they can
look yeah they can think that aphromoo
perform like CSV JSON excel others I'm
not mentioning right now and but the
drawback panel is done with a large data
sets like think over a gigabyte you can
get a little slow so sometimes it's good
to set the chunking parameter or for the
for for whatever you're reading to your
data in or using the library desk which
tasks desk specialized for using
multiple processors simultaneously so
you know so you know so here's the code
so the under first code here the DFT
this is kind of like well I
the code I used and here's some here's I
would look for like pandas chunking with
a chunk size of I think it's about a
million there and then and then if use a
dashed code that's the desk and the bomb
that so it's like how you'd read from a
CSV and all these functions sharing from
CSV files that's in case you're
wondering
and then I've upload the map you got you
something called geo panda I use
something called geo pandas so geo
pandas is pretty much is built on top of
pandas and pretty much what it does is
it enables enables enables you to to
read and write spatial data so spatial
data typically in the form of a geo JSON
file a shapefile kilo package and so for
making interactive map after you want
read in some type of some type of
spatial data so you can take an overlay
it with other data you're interested in
so here's here's an example of my uh of
my key of my my Geo pandas object my Geo
data frame it's this table over here and
one thing you notice about it is that it
has a geometry column here it's got and
essentially what the geometry column is
it kind of tells you what shape your
objects are end and usually like
expecially when dealing with maps we're
matching tons of irregular shapes you'd
be do a lot of polygons and multi
polygons and generally what a multi
polygon object is it's just it's a list
of a series of longitude and latitude
coordinates and it's usually the the X
variables you leave the latitude and the
Y is the longitude in case you're
wondering
and these are some huge lists so I saw
it you know so once you reading all the
data it's time to clean and merge them
so pretty much they're like um for
instance like drilling one data
I took if it has like going back here
drill one that I have here it's about
three four columns
I'm always personally not the only
interested in five or six of them at
most at any one time so it's a lot it's
a lot of those column de to be dropped
and you know in hindsight after I built
this I kind of learned there's a way you
can drop columns from being uploaded in
the first place so I guess the next
erasing of this I will be dropping those
columns but what kind of for now it's uh
let's see here okay so you know so I
dropped it sorry the drop those so I
dropped those approximately little less
than thirty irrelevant columns to make
this and then I'd to add some additional
columns which in my case each column I
had from the trio and desks that didn't
have a month variables so I would have
to you know so essentially I would have
to convert each created date thing I
made it slide 12 which back here for
reference where I highlighted this thing
I've to convert this is not in date time
this was and I think in a string format
so the convergence in date time which is
a specialized format where you can
easily extract what the weekday the year
the month of a certain day day is so
they're gonna merit to a month and then
I had to pick a column to Mirza
generally when you Mirjana gonna merge
column from between two - sets make sure
to make sure the columns are very very
similar so I choose to merge down like
the neighborhood council name for the or
the Geo data set and then for the true
one data set because they were they were
essentially the same and in this too and
this is the code I used to merge geo
pandas and pandas and I still have also
put there to clean it as well so the
trimmer' function here a text and what I
did was was a pretty much just trimmed
down the true in one data frame and then
two to one twenty twenty two five
variables I was interested in at that
time and then so and then the month
convert month convert is kind of what I
used to
you know to you know to convert date
times I had that's createdate one here
to convert create day one into well not
convert but the adding you month column
and then the monthly call volume is kind
of what I did to kind of calculate like
how much like how many calls were made
in each month per neighborhood council
door nine not there ninety nine
neighborhood councils in Los Angeles so
I would had to make you know so they're
at the ostensibly ninety nine columns
when I was doing this monthly call
volume function and the Geo merger that
someone actually does emergency that's
the one that takes and the do the Geo
data frames called geo file parameter
and the data frame here which is the
parameter for the for the pandas data
frames and Congress merges them together
and I merge them on the name of the
neighborhood council so now why bouquet
so you know so the reason why I use
bouquet is because when you're using
when you're making interactive maps you
think of your standard visualization
library it's like matplotlib I think
I'll tear is getting a little more
popular now and what's the other one
otere there's plot lib and flatly well
no plot leaves actually I think probably
could could be up to the task
but Seabourn yes Seabourn yes think of
Seaborn yeah those three you know like I
look pretty hard but sometimes like
handling callbacks or hand especially
handling callbacks is I do not find any
capabilities nodes package now if
someone can find them for me please tell
me because I would love I'd love to see
an example but I couldn't find any so
that's why I use bouquet and just more
generally what makes a library suitable
for an interactive map one is to be
asked to handle a lot of data so as so
so you'll be easily dealing with data
that could be over a gigabyte so they
kind of give you a perspective like how
much of how much data you have to you
have to work with and to you'll be able
to handle callbacks so just would be for
us or well the callback is pretty much
like let's say if your user clicks on
like just to go back to this example to
these slides I have here would be to
like like you can't see
it's may here and this light here and
then over here it's February so pretty
much what happens is like what you want
exchange monster like when I wanted to
take these but like selecting you month
here or sucking new year with these
buttons here essentially essentially
this map has a deal to a call back it
has to be has to be query the data is a
query the data table I made or just be
able making you one and has to be able
to and has to take that that new data it
has to be able to post it to to display
it and as a further example let me see
here yes just so you can just kind of
see it live here you go so y'all can see
this right okay here we go and then we
pick June please run okay here we go
so yeah you can kind of see that there
so so kind of it so you know so if you
want to do that there or have the user
defined what are the change that can
happen you need to you know you need to
be able to Andale callbacks
and bouquet does give you capability to
do that so but before he keeps bouquet
you have to convert your data source
into one that's usable by bouquet and
for bouquet it's something called a
column data source and so you know so so
pretty much what I did here with this
with this code here is that it's a
column data source maker so it context
into the you know the you know the Geo
data frame I kind of merge from the last
section of code from slide 18 here it
kind of takes the it count takes the the
value returned from geo merger here and
it R and it puts and put and it kind of
runs in as the parameter here and it's
also just get poly chords function would
you get poly chords pretty much what it
does is it gets the it gets the X&Y
coordinates or in your graphic terms its
x coordinates the latitude Y coordinates
the longitude and it makes it makes you
columns forum in the in the Geo data
frame and then and then so it's kind of
going out here the latitude and
longitude is being made here and and of
course we kind of get rid of some
unnecessary data out here
unnecessary column here at this point
and then we making U and then we make a
new column source or a new column data
source I just say and now we have this
thing called update function and pretty
much what the update function does is
that it updates the map so essentially
so essentially so essentially this is
the thing that actually runs the call
this is a kind of thing that runs the
callback yeah you know so it's the
backend of this application so the user
so kind of let's go you know kind of go
back here it's kind of like when I you
know when I pick something new here like
a new month for instance something
what's going on is that update function
or you know it takes in the info I put
in it kinda talks I put a new month and
you know it kind of tells the back I'll
you on the backend and tells the
database saying hey we need these you
know we need this new we need out for
January now and then it kind of runs
that query building your - source and
then displays it over here so
something with the update function does
and here's my update function over here
so you know so it's kind of like you
know since I'm the only doing two years
now it wasn't it wasn't too complicated
and you know so I guess in a feature
recoding I can always call it in the
middle here between like after the if
statement and after the else statement
it can be I could turn into its own
function for a separation of concern but
but for now but for now pretty much with
this if function does here is like it if
rail bun active like so the radio button
is set to 2019 that's what I mean by
active to one it can you don't create is
you know going query based on the year
2019 and then but if it's not if it's
not 2018 or 0 or else they're only two
options you're gonna create a new it's
gonna create is going to query 2018 data
set and the push notebook here just for
Jupiter notebook this line here it's
kind of like if you want to get your if
you wanna get displayed if you want if
you want to show function to work later
on which I'll get to what show is you
have to use push notebook so okay if you
want to make visuals one way to do is
you got you gotta use the figure yeah
use the figure constructor it's like
it's a class and essentially uh and
figure and something what figure does
it's just an example your site you can't
see the background here like it's white
space here that's that's the figure
that's an empty figure so you can think
of the figure here at the canvas they
put the drawing on and the drawing
itself though is handled by something
called the passes attribute so the past
is attribute that's the you know that's
the drawing itself that's all that's
lost the city Los Angeles that's all the
neighborhood councils and and of course
if you want to make an interactive map
it's crucial day you allow callbacks
they have some way to deal with
callbacks from user sitting in you data
and now we have sub the bouquet figure
so it runs up the bulky figure we have
these tooltips here which is something
with tooltips what they do it's like you
know when I hover over this the tutu
velvet subs neighbor a council name and
call volume so the neighbor council name
you know that shows up and then we got
call volume here and that's set from
that code code out back there and also
and also like bouquet such so show
Cooper duper need it pretty much allows
you also to like easily define tools you
can you can add into your map so like I
got a hover tool I got a pan tool got
tap I have a wheel zoom tool which is
all pre so pretty neat and you know you
got a full list of tools here are
storing it's a bitly link there are tons
and tons of tools I haven't even gone
through it it's a pretty long page I
really recommend you to go through it
once these slides get posted on from PI
down feel free to go through its
PowerPoint and look at that link ton of
functions here and there and you can
actually do a ton you could do a lot
with bokeh a boat game X makes it so
simple how simple Ison Munson because
you can see here I have four features
here hover pan tap wheel zoom it's so
simple up to the point if I want to add
something new all I have to do is just I
guess extend the string a little bit I
just have to just add let's say fifth
parameter if I want to take out tap for
instance I could have a delete tap here
that's it so simple I'll say something
figures dot patches so we got the canvas
setup but now but now we want to like
paint something on it we want to make we
don't put something there so in this
case we have to do figures patches and
figures about passes prints what it does
is it takes in a data source here which
in this case I called the under called
the unsourced here and essentially what
and remember for bokeh we need column
data source so we need a column data
frame
so essentially unsourced is equal to a
column data frame object and then and we
take the column data frame object and
then we pass it into the source
parameter of p1 patches
and essentially what this does they tell
it tells that it tells the patches it
kind of tells the patches method that
are you know that here's the day of
surgery you're gonna be looking at and
and these two first premise here to X
and the y column if you remember from
earlier X corresponds to longitude
latitude Y corresponds to longitude so
it essentially tells patches to to label
all the latitude and longitude
coordinates from from this source
parameter here which the comdata frame
of interest and then we have a fill
color which is essentially what fill
color does it's kind of like it allows
you to set the scale and determine the
color so you know if you kind of look
here my map for instance I don't know if
you could tell her or not but lighter
color means less call volume so so you
see neighborhood Hill I got around Hills
for instance they don't have too much
color so we're lawyers say the yellow
but over here for instance Van Nuys at
law calls so it's darker the dark so
it's a pretty dark shade of blue and
this color scheme is actually defined in
this line here and by reading the brewer
by Brewer a bouquet Brewer object and
goes yellow green blue kind of sets up
like a scale there yellows light green
is moderate blue is severe and now you
know so kind of you know so this
function here sets up that the call that
a calls column from the column data
source object will be used to will be
will be what's labeling the interactive
map and the transform color mapper is
what transforms what gets the color
scheme up there and of course line color
black and lying with excellence with the
term separates the neighborhoods so in
further long you want to add controls
and you know format the layout so adding
buttons and widgets is super easy in
bouquet like these two lines of code
here for instance because that allows me
to make the button let's call this is
specifically radio bunny or so this bun
here actually was actually may have only
lot one line of course only may have
this line up here I'm hovering hovering
over and and update is actually run
through this one here
and then everyone the drop-down menu
drop-down menu select and and in the
update function a callback on the
exception is over here so you know so
you know so bouquet allows you to do and
that's amazing and then over here
controls I can step in one one box both
the button and the drop-down menu and
then I merge them with the P one object
which P one is my name for the figures
object here it merge them into one row
and then it finally adds it to the dock
and in the dock and the dock is pretty
much where everything is lying that's
the canvas of the canvas so the dock
it's like it's like this whole big thing
here like this the figures this empty
thing here the patches is this map here
a canvas but the dock is everything it's
like this white space here so and then I
also have a modified dark function so
modify dock functions that's what things
to stay at the app so the update runs
the callback but modified dock is what
updates everything so and then in the
way and the modified dock is actually is
way is up which this definitely needs a
rebase recoding but pretty much modify
dock is this gigantic method here if i
dock it always takes in the dock a dock
as uh as a parameter and then pretty
much pretty much i squished every
function i made so far into it and then
so so as I said this code will be will
be going up it was already up on github
but it'll be going up you know I'll be
I'll be reporting it again so y'all can
look through it but it's pretty big and
I definitely and then if possible I
definitely will be recording it so it's
a lot more compact and easier true to
manage and deal with so and then of
course like I primarily dealt with loop
their notebook and you've their hub but
definitely if you want to put it but
they're definitely other ways you can
put them interactive map to up like
bouquet doesn't give you a lot of
options like you can you know you can
you can even do a cow code in JavaScript
if you want to so you can handle all
like the callbacks and browser you only
server which if you do them Python you
do need a server and I am using Google
Cloud as my as my hosting platform right
now so you know so just a heads up with
another JavaScript person it's not
JavaScript conference mm-hmm
so so I run a Python so so this is a
kind of code here to get everything into
the application object
I passed the function modify doc in a
function handler and it passed the
handler into the application so of
course you know running everything on
your own little notebook is fine your
notebook is fine but what one so two
others so you have two options one day
if you rerun the old code themselves
which no one wants to do that or you can
put up like let's say on Jupiter hub so
you know so if one put on the under on
Jupiter hub you need an additional
function and this is pretty much because
if you put on on the cloud for instance
you're using a proxy URL and it's one
function I'll show you in a second show
can't can't attack what URL is ply on so
you have to essentially tell it what URL
you have to do and this function here is
taken from the bokya documentation of
how to build a remote jupiter proxy URL
it just the only trick with it is that
you can't see here the first line here
the OS environ external URL variable
this thing here is that I had to you
have to define it manually in your Gupta
hub environment so you know you have to
define and you define the external URL
to the URL your to your link in your
Jupiter hub notebook so for mine for
instance kind of what I did here it was
also defined okay you can see here in
column 3 and Row 3 here
like an intro through year usually
defining it like um you know that's my
that's your all I use that's my user
that's my user name and that's the three
that's the tree three file so probably
so probably when you do it it'll be
it'll be something similar when I set up
[Music]
goodness anyway so um well yeah yeah
good thing is we're pretty much done
anyway so like all the next few slides
like all day which so is pretty much saw
it pretty much pretty much have a link
to like this show the app and notebook
URL so this is running on Google cloud
right now so I have this notebook URL
parameter attached but if you're just
run right in Google Notebook here just
so you know this doesn't run locally on
my computer here you see the localhost
8080 was four eights tough tough crowd
but you know so you see us here it's you
know so there's a run locally so you see
here my show method only has show app
but Sam Ryan's on cloud I need this
notebook
I need a notebook URL equal to stuff
remote looped or proxy URL function like
this thing here so that's pretty much it
that's kind of how you make a map on
using using a Python server and then
putting up on the Google cloud so it's
essentially kind of one exercised of
taking in some data merging it
reformatting as needed and again some
new columns and then find good color
scheme and then visualizing it on a map
and you know and then so I learned that
or any questions so if you have your own
longitude and latitude you can put like
locations or dots or whatever but does
it have some preset conditions for it's
a California or states or cities so you
don't have for drawing the outline well
like well I dunno bokade it does have
like something preset for United States
and for the world for California itself
I'm not
so sure I wouldn't wanna be surprised
and I don't like exactly looking and
seeing as California was on there but
you can definitely go to like Google
search bouquet California map you might
you might find something or every google
logged geo data frame california you
might you might find it I'm pre cert or
something on the repeal diaphragm
California so one of the like problems
with creating a visualization is having
the data in the first place so how
common is it to find for example you
just on four different scales of maps
and things like that
well how common is well it can actually
be a little more common they think
because I'm like NASA for instance and
they're like lots of other like
state-run Geographic in Spain sea level
or in geographic services they do they
do have a lot of our what's it called
data well here's the obesity chart I'm
gonna move away from this now so like oh
like I work on my dad from was like from
a city of Los Angeles itself so be dad
off LA City maps for instance you know
you know you would go l a Geo city hub
here and when it decides to load up you
cannot like you know find maps they're
like I think there's even la Metro bus
route map here like yeah you can find
the shapefile right here of the of the
la la bus maps which which say follows a
perfectly acceptable map you can use to
make to make an interactive map for
instance so your common business there
and let's see what those download
options they have here mo that's the
api's yeah goj some over here link to
geo JSON so so like so la for instance a
Los Angeles it's awesome with this - I
don't know York it's awesome as well I
think Chicago is getting awesomer I'm
not totally sure yet but but there you
go it really depends on staying local
level and some international services
but there is a lot out there thank you
so how well does Bill Kate deal with
real-time data real-time data
um there is a streaming option for
bouquet there's a stream object I have
not personally play around with it so I
can't say but from what I hear it does
it can't do the job it can't be
effective you know when you have to
select
first you want to use for build in the
model is there like any advice that you
can provide so so generally so generally
if we're gonna build a model first off
you want to show something like like
building a map anyway it's kind of like
telling a story so in many ways what you
want is like you want to like pick like
let's say you want to pick a feature
that's they have a feeling that might
change over time or might be different
for different geographic areas like back
to my example here like the heat map of
Los Angeles here for instance it's like
I'm either feeling that it'll be true
one calls will be different for
different neighborhoods so I kind of
just you know so I kind of like got to
death for three long calls made for two
whole years almost two whole years now
and I uh and you know and I kinda showed
it over here so you can I just have to
have like um like a better you gotta
have an intuition of what might be
different for different areas like
different features for different
geographic areas and when I say graphic
area it can be something as big as a
country or it could be something as
small as a neighborhood or sometimes
even the smell is a parcel but the
partials pretty much is like small it is
a small you know very small it's like
premise a building so soon so it really
comes down to like white why you on
display and what feature what feature
you want to show and hopefully it would
be one that has changed over time for
different areas but if I have on the tip
code instead of longitude and latitude
information can I still using the
bouquet may repeat again um but if I
only have a deep coat zip code
information well if you only have zip
code it may be a little tricky because
because with because like I'm not
necessary where's the zip code phone
symbol we could do is that there are
there are ways you can convert a zip
code into approximate land to the
latitude very very accurate within
decimal places and if you if you want to
do that I'd recommend first conversion
zip code data into a longitude latitude
for net
corn and then putting those coordinates
into a polygon ideally Multi polygon
object then put it then doing this what
do you have any metrics for after you
created the application for people using
it
like an uptick or how was that gauged
how was that gauged well I didn't get
that far yeah so I didn't release this
to the public yet but uh you know but
you know but you know boy I get to that
point there there should be a way that I
can uh yeah yeah I could kind of like a
nudge there like how many you know like
how many unique users feel coming from
unique IP addresses are are you are
using that are using this map and you to
be able to count them but I haven't gone
that far yet it's not it's not public
and is there any other any it's uh it's
almost break time so break I guess